[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
khater de jean luc lemoine après on
verra les coulisses de touche pas à mon
poste avec ce credo par année mais pas
bien sûr mon ami maxime j'ai dit bonjour
luc négative alors alors avec qui vous
partez en vacances sans pression sans
rien sans elle
quoi non mais j'ai jamais répondu
d'accord bas dans le hockey très bien on
reste sur la richesse j'ai dit voilà je
cherchais dit les deux noms magath avait
engagé la guerre après la dic a dit oui
parce que gatti était méchante ah bon
oui bon gars mais finalement c'est
maxime où toi c'est le même à ces
annonces jeudi agathe
à l'époque c'était est ce que voulait
une question oui la dernière de l'année
oui allez tout de suite une question
qu'il soit par bonjour je m'appelle
marie claire j'ai cru comprendre que vos
vacances d'été avec mon ancienne 14 juin
donc j'ai deux choses à vous dire qu'ils
nous avons dû votre calendrier et de
bonnes vacances
ceignac à l'arrivée je vous remercie
chère marie claire mais mais tout le
monde ne part pas en vacances a il faut
le préciser les programmes continus sur
s'est vite contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser que ces soirées car je
vous rappelle que dès lundi benjamin
présentera de nouveau numéro de on fait
moins d'audience amélété
[Rires]
mais bien avant va cartonner et c'est
pas non mais parce que des gens dont les
toits enfin excuse moi est ce que c'est
parce que déjà normal et pas toi
ouais c'est vrai parce que vous vous
avez toujours refusé de me remplacer
c'est vrai parce que j'étais remplaçable
oh là là on sort le paravent ya rien à
personne parce que déjà qu'en temps
normal nos jours c'est compliqué
d'affaires de la avec la coupe du monde
c'est un vrai acte de foi
alors moi je te regarderai montpetit
kamikaze regarderai way pour le reste
certains vont prendre du repos et c'est
tant mieux car je vais vous dire la
vérité beaucoup sont au bout du rouleau
jean-michel par exemple en ce moment il
fait le tour du platon balançant ses
vannes sans y croire et surtout sans
comprendre pourquoi valérie a l'air
moins cliente qu'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
je suis plus de ce titre c'est dadou que
j'adore je suis comme un oeuf sur lui
mais jamais aucun rapport avec la
chanson ce qui est bien c'est que en
fait des tenues de tout ça vous avez
retenu que ouais bon a pas dû le faire
ce magnéto non mais c'est sûr que quand
jean michel a raconté cinquante deux
fois la même 28 mar - c'est comme quand
tu discute tous les jours avec les mêmes
personnes au bout d'un moment tu as tout
dit tout les semaines qui leur a demandé
s'ils avaient un gros saisir une belle
chatte tu tourne un peu en rond
l'animal animal la conversation je vais
vous montrer
c'est ce qu'on appelle une conversation
de fin de saison je suis pas là
à chaque fois
vraiment
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
c'est vrai que catastrophe mais je me
rappelle année sur besoin de terres
foule commence à caler chaleur pac il
faut passer aucun problème il faut qu'il
se repose cyril il supporte plus rien en
plus quand on lui passe un extrait de
n'oubliez pas les paroles
autant lui amener une corde mais cette
chance trois cas pas d'émissions qui
vaut moins qu'un
meiway sourire mais j'aurais voulu tu
t'endors oui pendant les manier touche
juste sur cette chanson que vous allez
non mais je déteste cette chanson et
c'est ça qui est en cause mais ce que je
peux un autre qui a besoin de repos
c'est maxime guinée a besoin de repos
des premiers lui il a fait une année
très riche puisque en moins de neuf mois
il avait même écrit trois dictionnaires
de nouveaux mots à chaque fois c'est ça
la vie alors que pour que vous puissiez
les assimiler pendant l'été ces nouveaux
mots je vous ai fait une petite copine
et nouveaux mots de maxime guinée
je trouve qu'elles sont de magnifiques
photos en noir et blanc le blanc couleur
méconnu oh regarde le ciel bleu et les
nuages blancs c'était une vraie belle
brummel chauffe reibel surnom de jean
paul belmondo va épouser meygal hockey à
2700 invités au château un chalon
insultes avec choix tu mens et je pêche
de château on va encore de nikos aliagas
à la matinale d'europe 1 la manie qui
dit nan matinal des gens qui ont trop bu
la veille au soir
la famille royale famille cousine de la
famille consonnes marina ça sera sur tf6
présentée par karine ferri karine ferri
fille de karen cheryl et luc ferry max
et moi je n'aime pas parce que je trouve
qu'il s'agit d'une accusation une
réalisation accusations réaliser en même
temps qu'un machin très gros cerveau il
ya deux tiers des français qui rêvent de
changer de vie 68 7 % 60 suisse %
pourcentage de suisse dans la population
mondiale est ce la chaîne est toujours
joker du 20h le jt de 20h devoir
conjugal des couples qui se couche tôt
j'ai mis un petit on me dit tu vas
décontracté on s'approche du week-end
week end moment de la semaine réservé à
la détente
ce week-end j'ai juil
[Musique]
c est l épargne il n'est pas difficile à
faire ce magnéto dans aura aussi quand
même il faut être patient ça arrive ça
va bouger avant sa passe à l'eau qui dit
fin de saison dit aussi disparition
d'émissions ça c'est moins rigolo
la semaine dernière on apprenait l'arrêt
des guignols et je sais pas pourquoi
à ce moment là valérie a tenu à rendre
hommage aux marionnettes et à cyril en
même temps
riche idée regardez bien les têtes en
sortie de magnéto c'est magique on sent
que si elle aurait pu s'en passer de
cette séquence voici monsieur vous avez
votre mot à huy
ben je crois qu'on a un extrait d'un
coussin péteur se prit aussitôt
d'affection pour l'enfant qu'elle décide
à des levées comme son propre coup ça où
le raisin mais on l'habille à eon
l'intégra à une émission de télé jouer
sa lutte et beauté
quand on va en trouver
[Applaudissements]
merci va les rives
merci pour demain merci non c'est rien
c'est tout ce qu'on aime on sent qu'elle
a subi plus à la fin en tout cas c'est
une magnifique transition pour le top
j'ai dans sa wii cette agglomération des
moments bizarres de tnt un top gênant
s'il commence aujourd'hui par benjamin
casse tête
[Musique]
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous est ce
que voulait jouer à wii
une formidable c'est que c'est un
révélateur de comportements n'ont cessé
la région se bidonner
[Musique]
gemma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que ce que l'entreprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ce que dit quand même d'articles
étaient pas faux c'est que les chaînes
de la tnt pour les gens prennent bien en
général le coût de grille c'est à dire
l'entièreté des années
[Musique]
blake sont des animaux qui s'attache
très vite à vous
à
[Musique]
serge aurier nadal d'où il sait qu'il
est plus fort que moi ban s'est jamais
rencontré de façon aussi me rencontrons
voici pourquoi pas
j'adore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça résume est bien quand j'ai
entendu agathe je vais partir avec kelly
pour vous décider
parce que moi je fais des réservations
alors j'aurais pu être une autre
séquence dans ce top tendance c'est le
passé deux des films wespiser la semaine
dernière vous avez dit qu'il viendrait
peut-être d'ailleurs je vous ai entendu
ce matin
oui c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup voilà
j'aime beaucoup delphine et je la trouve
excellent bon alors il afin que la bonne
chronique est des choses changent parce
que ça s'est passé moyens de les voir ça
commence par un magnéto sur bernard
montiel gens qui est malheureusement
benjamin lancar mois va vouloir faire le
malin auprès de la jolie ex miss france
est une de mes vidéos préférées là on
est passé à la femme d'argent
la femme vénale
la veuve noire enfin son panier parce
qu'un bras qu'elle essayait de canal et
donc séparé retrouvera sa chute
tuning prévenant que l'on arrive à se
décanter
entrée c'est cette chambre vous avez 15
et amendé 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est énorme elle était là que tu étais
folle ça fait mal alors comme c'est la
fin d'année devrait aussi donner un
petit coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de
cette saison énorme où cyril a encore
repoussé les limites de la tnt car il
n'a pas l'air comme ça mais ce mec est
l'ambition ne ressemble à rien mais ça
winner alors quand il s'agit de
renouveler tpp est guetté ses
téléspectateurs il voit grand très grand
parfois trop mais peu importe dire
qu'une seule chose cyril merci merci de
nous avoir fait rêver
[Musique]
toute l'équipe devra monter un spectacle
de chants de danses une comédie musicale
j'adore on fera un grand prime on le
joie à bordeaux et non puisque pour le
23 juin
on va partie non non non aliza non non
pour l'enterrement de vie de garçon âgé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette qui vont partir à marrakech
puisqu'on va partir pour le ba-ba rakesh
3 décembre
mais non
est-ce que tu serais prêt à faire la
veille de la sortie de taxi donc le dise
le 10 avril le 10 avril
ouais en direct de marseille touche pas
à mon père si tout va bien c'est fait
oui je sais on en parle moins 9 janvier
maintenant je suis le 9 janvier à
toulouse avec by claude on est dans la
merde
non mais je vous dis y aura en prime on
sait pas quand mais y'aura va
[Musique]
entamée au défi de faire une émission à
toulouse est allé le 9 janvier j'veux
pas pourquoi
arema 9 janvier l'anniversaire de ré et
puis surtout ça veut dire ça va bien
puis surtout le 9 janvier chez le temps
de préparer
[Musique]
fera un grand tour de france je vous le
dis voilà pas trop encore et jamais elle
avec moi à chaque fois dans un avion
janaudy fans 12 10 personnes voilà qui
ont envie de venir et je les ramènerais
tous sur ce plateau
voli jeffrey dix villes de france
environ 48 heures
[Musique]
vincent mutel cela se compare les
génériques il en train de nous composé
le générique de l'année prochaine de
terrain
[Musique]
c'est que à partir d'aujourd'hui on
s'échauffe et camille ce week-end
d'après lui il permettra un sketch tous
les deux tous les soirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi ici il ya une seule personne qui
incarne marianne c'est bernard montiel
en récoltant les ché est-ce que l'alcool
n'a mené sur les gérants sûr que non oui
on me l'a dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non franchement c'est non et alzheimer
choix mettant rappelle vraiment mais je
me rappelle vraiment absent tout faire
l'année prochaine voilà fait toujours
rire et ça fait l'année prochaine on
fera le tour de france puisse invoquer
les champs elysées pendant une
demi-heure et la honte du siècle on
n'était pas là dessus merci l'avez vous
étiez superbe jean luc tu m'as tu es là
la raisonner et il ya des gens qui sur
twitter ça le résume tellement pas tout
merci mesdames ans après juin merci oui
oui non certes vous avez envie des
choses vraies
vous voulez le partage et puis après on
passe à autre chose évidemment j'ai
travaillé la marge pas méchant mais non
c'est pas méchant mais vous vous
improvisez tout le temps donc forcément
il ya des vagues garage basse et vous
nous avez donné tellement d'autres
choses qui me connaît bien
bon on aurait pu rajouter laurent gerra
sur scène enfin toutes les promesses
coup voilà merci qu'il y ait à roland
garros sur à peine d'amendé quelque
chose ouais là le complexe je pars avec
toi à toi laisser votre week-end à
deauville et non en beauté mais oui
chérie comme hergé dans ces cas là le
déjeuner ou le dîner ça fait trois ans
et la loire en vie il n'a pas envie j'ai
fait le coup à tout le monde mais ce que
je sais que c'est vrai que pour roland
garros il m'a dit on y va et on déjeune
ensemble donc le matin à 11 heures
j'avais maintenu mon petit short et à 11
heures de ma chambre à 11h 11h30 12h
12h30 13h30 jure que c'est vrai à 15h40
j'ai mon bébé tu le vis bien devant
canal du public comme foot et je
t'attends 15h30
il a dit je dis bah alors quatre ans que
l'on attendait t'as pas vu les matches
bah non il pleuvait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cagnina plus on est parti c'est vrai on
s'est bien amusé et ce malgré
l'important c'est qu'on était ensemble
cela exactement
merci enfin jean luc tu nous tue ce soir
tu es notre bon vieux d un peu plus ou
mal aux genoux mais comme s'il vous
plaît et on commence par une news passé
dans le village people de la semaine
dernière concernant pamela anderson et
adil ramaré et surtout une master class
de présentation et cyril hanouna qui une
nouvelle fois va se transformer au
moment du retour antenne au niveau de la
maîtrise des émotions
ce mec est un génie
[Musique]
l'occasion pour elle d'évoquer son coup
de foudre pour le français j'ai craqué
pour sa moustache mais aussi celle
qu'avait pas tomber sur gérard jugnot
cité fait qu'être par jarju nous a alors
croisé autre affaire celle chercher de
moustache on a compris et on a chaque et
chaque goutte troupes
enfin groupe chanter un chant devant le
pape et moi j'ai des sollicitations la
haine
[Musique]
mais mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
1910 nous permet pas les dents
nrg je crois oui
c'était quoi ça c'est des cafards
[Applaudissements]
et
non mais
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup
vendus
faudra pendant la pub sur le fait
chausser public est chauffé le public m
[Applaudissements]
les goûts
[Musique]
c'est beau et c'est insupportable
[Applaudissements]
non mais
je vais y arriver
la monuc
des personnages qui sont capables rien
n'arrête pas ton armée sur cette
capacité de dissimulation je pense que
de nombreux auteurs
déjà parce que des années il y avait
deux catégories dans le même temps plus
adapté
[Musique]
j'avais du nord et du ciment
l'agencé craint
je
on dit bien avec evander holyfield parce
que c'était un grand champion aussi on
sait tous ce qui s'est passé on faisait
des potes vraiment super pote vous aimez
beaucoup en fait vous avez tourné ce
petit sketch ensuite c'était c'était
vraiment votre pote même après tout ce
qui s'est passé
[Musique]
vrai que la venue ce très fort mon amie
catherine saison exceptionnelle georges
leroy
[Applaudissements]